our guys have the worst hygiene like
Richard Christie had 12 cavities at one
time yeah because icky and got under
what dentist his entire life
well if dad was afraid of dentists
Richard I heard you're going on a limb
dentist your sister went to one one fat
didn't turn out good Richard used to
clean his teeth with a towel like what
growing up I don't know but that's what
he said you should just like wipe them
down with it why a towel oh here Sal
sounds got info so well we used to tour
years ago right we would share hotel
rooms right so I'm in the bathroom one
morning I'm brushing my teeth and
Richards laying the bed he goes what the
hell are you doing brushing your teeth
what are you doing because we're on
vacation yeah to do that I go what am I
supposed to do so he he pushes me out of
the way in the bathroom and he grabs one
of those little soap rags and it just
rubs it over his teeth and those are the
rigs that guys jerk off into oh my god I
like Sal telling the story tells you
something even grosser who goes into a
hotel and jerks off into a little
towelette yeah don't wipe your teeth on
there that's where I jerk off no Richard
told one of us because I remember
hearing this story that he was saying
matter-of-factly that he had brushed his
teeth once during his entire high school
yeah he's proud of that how does that
happen did he never have a girlfriend
one time during your entire high school
is that true why because I started
getting really bad canker sores just
because my mouth was so gross and I had
to get canker sore medicine from a
doctor and I've tried brushing my teeth
I was like why do that if I could just
take the canker sore medicine doesn't it
feel good when you brush your teeth it
does now I love it now
it only took him 40 years back then it
didn't my three year old brush is
[ __ ] I said Richard teeth are the
work of the devil do you try eating
something without your teeth that's what
a real name gum it tell you I made my
first set of teeth out of raccoon
opossum in the blender when I first got
like dental insurance I went nuts I had
a lot of work to do I know we remember
when you had 12 cavities yeah two root
canals
[Laughter]
there's my business potential just went
out of business
how's it possible I have 12 counties
free we have 70 we got two cavities of
117 canker sores one two
[Music]